hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that to my guest
today is a scientist and not just any
old scientist because he is the man who
is the public face of what's been
described as the scientific discovery of
the decade and here he is Roth dieter oh
yeah thank you thank you very much for
coming to Berlin today to be here on
talking Germany great stuff now Ralph de
la jolla is the head of what is known as
San the giant particle physics
laboratory located near Geneva
Switzerland where they say that they
have almost certainly discovered the
particle or particles known as the higgs
boson and that they say could help us
unlock many of the secrets of the
universe it's fascinating stuff and we I
mean we could begin with the micro
science I don't really want I want to
start with feelings you're the man who
is at the heart of this project that may
lead to giving us the key to unlock the
secrets of the universe what does it
feel like good oh it feels great I mean
it if you would have much more time I
could describe you how this feeling
started to develop and to increase in a
more and more positive sense over the
period of 12 months it was an amazing
period until we could finally say we
have it yeah i mean let's go back to
july 2012 last year when when when you
made the initial announcement that thing
it looked very good that you had made
the discovery you'd been seeking to make
there were scientists in that room where
you made the announcement i mean you're
a football fan yeah they were scientist
who were going around like this as
though they'd scored a goal just
described that in that emotional feeling
being in the middle of it it was
fantastic no and also the the leaders of
the experiments who announced their
results they felt the same way we were
all touched overwhelmed and only
realized a little bit later what'd she
have found their what we have made their
mmm that's fantastic and then all this
good work has been done at the
organization that you are the head of
CERN in Switzerland near Geneva tell us
a little bit more about the organization
so that we're in the picture there the
organization was founded 1954
the first discussion started 1949
shortly after the world war and there
were people with a lot of foresight with
a lot of vision also the word vision is
sometimes miss us but they had a vision
and their vision was we need to have a
laboratory where we can compete with
other regions and such a laboratory is
too big for a single country and so 12
countries signed the original treaty in
1954 today we are 20 countries and we
have several countries in accession to
membership so despite the fact that we
are nearly 60 years old we are still
attractive mmm the 20 countries that are
on board so far they're all European
countries the other countries who were
wanting to get involved these days who
were they they are also from Europe and
also from outside europe because 2010 we
made a historic decision on the
political or the diplomatic side we have
changed the e the meaning of the e in
CERN from Europe to everywhere yeah that
is our country is independent of that
your graphical location can become
members or associate members mmm and now
we are getting more and more countries
who wants who want to become involved
because they see it not only as a
scientific institution but as an
institution where you work for peace so
it is science for peace or it is science
diplomacy just explain us a little bit
more how do you work for peace working
at CERN first of all it was founded
shortly after the world one more so to
have the countries working together in
science at that moment was already
helping the peace process yeah or the
the under under the process of
understanding each other and today we
have around hundred nationalities
registered at CERN who come so people
with these nationalities I come to CERN
do their research work and we have
people from India working with people
from Pakistan people from Israel is
working with people from the Palestinian
territories and that all works because
we just speak one single language and
stays science because science is a
universal language and then you can work
together it works fantastically
really there is stuff a great message
first insights there from Rolf D Toya
here is more bullsh t Doha is
director-general at CERN the swiss-based
laboratory were thousands of scientists
from all over the world carry out
particle physics research oya is both a
top manager and a committed physicist
who likes getting to the bottom of
things when he took on his post in early
2009 CERN was going through a difficult
phase a year earlier the Large Hadron
Collider or LHC had broken down shortly
after it went online the LHC the world's
largest particle accelerator is at the
heart of the CERN complex the financial
crisis back then also put pressure on
the budget the 20 countries
participating in the CERN project reined
in their contributions but despite the
cost-cutting measures he had to
implement the researchers still have
praised for their director before taking
decisions he is able to listen to
everybody in the field and very often he
gives a weight to what is listening so
he gives appreciation to the judgment
and opinions of the people he's a very
open very friendly smiling he is a very
special sense of humor that he maintains
also in a very delicate and difficult
situations
his gift for dealing with complexity was
noticed when he was still at school boy
I went on to study physics in Stuttgart
near his hometown of bull and struggled
at first with the syllabus he got his
doctorate in 1977 in Heidelberg he
worked at various institutes in Germany
and taught at the University of Hamburg
he's always been involved in basic
research he's also loved football since
his youth and plays as a goalkeeper
well Seto Hoya describes himself as an
incurable optimist a useful trait in the
field of science where there are always
setbacks he's guided CERN successfully
through hard times but here where
scientists are trying to confirm
theories on the structure of matter
there have also been repeated successes
to celebrate at the globe CERN's new
landmark and visitors center the public
can learn how physicists detect new
particles created by the collisions in
the LHC one of Hoyas tasks is to
communicate what basic research is and
to explain that the Large Hadron
Collider at CERN does not create black
holes or explosives from antimatter as
some Hollywood films have claimed the
physicist is involved in the ambitious
scientific goal of explaining the
universe around us from the Big Bang to
the present and beyond and today these
are guests on talking Germany North dito
hiya Andrews TTYL when when people like
me are talking about science we often
tend to say there are people who are
good at science and people who are not
so good at science what's the difference
between the two the difference is that
people who are good on science they have
overcome the threshold to work with
scientific methods and the others are
still in front of the threshold and they
should jump about a closet because
science can be rather easy that's on
strange but in my public talks I never
use equations hmm you can explain the
logic you cannot fully understand
everything at the end you need
mathematics for it but at least you can
explain what are the connections between
different things what is a logic behind
it and you can explain the fascination
and people should jump across that and
we saw what we saw some wonderful shots
of you in your early days there yeah
there is a long time exactly can you
remember a moment where that where the
fascination with science for you
actually began like a big bang yeah it's
cool in school I started at school yeah
it was a teacher it was
it was also a teacher yes because the
teacher was not demanding on that I
learned equations but he was exactly
demanding the logic and the experiments
I did in school they were completely
wrong I mean besides wrong yeah but I
learned what what are the problems to do
20 problematic it is to do easy
experiment yeah and then I thought okay
if it's if you can do this and you learn
the problems then you can also do more
complicated experiments okie dokie
you've got you've gone on you had a
successful academic career you've had a
successful career at CERN now you were
appointed in 2009 and I've got a cheeky
question for you if I may why did they
choose you you have to ask them oh come
on don't be so coy yeah well the point
you see you need somebody well it's my
job description you need somebody who is
accepted in the community yeah and you
need other somebody using accepted in
the community of the funding agencies
politicians diplomacy yeah and you need
somebody who has shown that he or she
can motivate people yeah can get people
to work together and not against each
other what is it I mean in the report
your described is a great you as a
manager you're described as a man who's
got a great sort of sense of humor that
you you use very strategic even the
British have to live I've heard you
described as a diplomat as a facilitator
where does all that come from in your
background how do you learn all that in
my jeans yeah I don't know I thought it
just comes like this because I don't
know because I may be my I don't like to
talk too much about myself but maybe
because I treat all people equally I
don't care if it's a taxi driver yeah or
somebody who cleans the office or if
it's a scientist how many people do you
have working for you um well we have a
staff we have nearly two and a half
thousand and plus 1,000 to our young
investigators also being paid by us yeah
and how the 11,000 scientific users
coming
so they are not working for me they are
usually working for themselves yeah
that's what you have to give them some
freedom yeah yeah but you also have to
focus a little bit deviation sometimes
hmm how many of them are very big egos
or quite a few but it's a heartache a
physicist you learn that the big ego
doesn't help you you can have the big
ego but if you don't give something to
the to your partners they won't give you
something and you are lost yeah because
it is it is the cliche that people i
mean people who haven't overcome the
threshold and got into science like
myself we have this idea that scientists
are really obsessed with themselves
obsessed with their own success looking
for the Nobel Prize maybe there are some
well this is a minority I think most are
obsessed or at least they are focusing
on finding out new things on the
knowledge gained yeah they are not so
much focused on themselves they want to
find something to learn something and
then they realize that we are so small
yeah and that that counts that you
realize that you find out where your
places okay you've got you've got all
these people working together for a huge
institution massive resources where does
the money come from it this day and age
I mean this is a deadly an age of
austerity that we're living in yeah but
I think it's exactly the point now to
invest in research because if you don't
invest in research now you break
something now that means you break part
of the you lose part of the future if
people in the 20th century would have
done the same thing maybe breaking or
stopping research we would live
completely differently and because we
already are doing is based on research
and a lot is based on basic research it
sounds like a difficult conversation
though that you must have on a regular
basis with the politicians because
you're what you're saying to them is i
can give you sub atomic insights but
then i want i want taxpayers money no I
tell them it's well invested taxpayers
money because what do they gain from
that they gain from that from that
extremely well-educated
young people yeah you should not forget
we have nearly three thousand young
people now performing their PhD thesis
at the Large Hadron Collider worldwide
and half of them immediately once they
received a PhD goat into the private
enterprise in the private sector so we
are educating for academia and at the
same time also for the private sector so
you you gain these knowledgeable people
who have learned to work in an
international environment which is more
and more important today because
everything global Isis and we have to
develop new technologies in order to do
this research so you gain immediately on
these things now gaining on directly for
society from our results themselves from
the research itself it's very difficult
to predict because it's basic science
that means you have a target and the tag
or goer this is to get knowledge you
know that this knowledge will bring you
further edit some stage it might be
useful for society but you don't know
when and you don't know where and there
is a very nice quote from mighty faraday
1850 when he was working on a study of
electricity his finance minister was
asking him mr. father is very nice what
you were doing there but what can it be
used for and his answer is the perfect
answer to my mind and he said honestly
sir I don't know it but maybe one day
you can tax it okay that would have gone
down well with the polity yes yeah okay
the organization we talked about Sam has
provided the backdrop the location for
as we've already seen a wee little bit
one of the great scientific adventures
of our time the hunt to track down the
Higgs particle it's a fascinating story
here it is july two thousand twelve the
scientists at the San research center
greeted the long-awaited news with a
huge round of applause
no se I think you have it you agree the
scientists have been searching for the
Higgs boson for decades finally they
were sure they'd found it it's the last
building block and the standard model of
quantum physics with which physicists
describe the structure of known matter
to conduct this basic research San built
the underground particle accelerator the
LHC near Geneva conditions inside the 27
kilometers long tunnel are quite extreme
hot see the LHC is the coldest ring in
the universe we don't know of any other
27 kilometers colder even outer space is
a bit warmer than the LHC ring bell mods
that's evening yeah inside two opposing
beams of protons are smashed together at
speeds close to that of light simulating
the state of the universe immediately
after the Big Bang huge detectors
measure the particles released by the
collision this is where the Higgs boson
left its traces it lends its mass to the
29 elementary particles known up until
now the Scottish physicist peter higgs
was visibly moved by the experimental
proof of the theory that he proposed
it's opened the way to a new chapter in
particle physics wonderful stuff seeing
Peter Higgs there are you when was the
first time in your life in your career
that you can actually remember hearing
the words Higgs particle must been a
long while ago it's a long way my logo
yes and because we are looking for this
beast since quite some time yet because
we knew everything about it more its
property is big because they are
predicted by the so-called standard
model yeah the only thing we did not
know does it exist at all yep that means
we did not know where its mass would be
and therefore we were searching since
quite some time and did you get what you
heard about the particle did you very
quickly think wow this is a challenge
for me this is a kind of a holy grail no
the Holy Grail is
the whole the whole project or just be
because the whole point goes far beyond
the Higgs particle and we are trying to
look for many many more things okay I
mean I'm using the language of the Holy
girl because I want to move on to
something I mean what you and I talked
to a couple of years ago and in the
press we'd have been hearing a lot of
journalists talking the media talking
about your work and they'd been using
this term God's particle yes and at the
time yeah I I you know I put it to you
is that useful is that relevant and you
said no yeah now I hear you've become a
little bit more accustomed to it that
was a quote that I heard what why it's
exactly as you say I still don't like
the the vert because it has nothing to
do with God because if God would have
created or if if you assume that God has
created all the particles then that all
particles should be called particles
yeah and not only this one but I have
been a I'm now our used to it so to
speak and I think it has helped us in
publicizing the result do you know how
it came about this name tell me if Leon
Lederman the Nova voice went off
absolute eyes yeah and he was writing a
book about product physics and
especially about this particle which is
so difficult to find yeah and he wanted
to call the book the goddamn particle
and his publisher said it will not sell
like this talk to them okay point made
all of the work you're doing and all of
the what you're telling me about it all
takes place against the backdrop of a
big debate that's been going on for at
least a decade probably longer about the
relationship between science and
religion what's your contribution to
that debate when we have started to
contribute to that debate and we we had
a first workshop in 2012 which we called
at the interface of knowledge now the
interface the interface of northern and
I call the interface of knowledge here
you have the results from science and
here you have what you can call believe
or philosophy etc
and I think there's a great sewn in
between and what has to talk together to
say this is owned in between us that
there's a gap there's an oil sorry
there's an overlap there's a level of
overlap yeah because some some of the
results are not yet accepted or some of
the results might be debatable but you
have first to find a common language now
because if scientists or physicists
cause something this is a proof hmm if
the Philosopher's cause at the proof
that's a different different meaning
behind the pool so we had a first
workshop where we had presentations by
scientists and presentations by
philosophers and also people from
theology just to see how the talkingest
and now we have to see how to continue
that dialogue but that happens at at
several places and I think we have to do
that more and more because after all we
should not work in isolation mm-hmm we
have to to talk to each other there was
one time does the Karma be who it was
but I can remember reading this that a
one scientist said science is also about
making a leap of faith I'm not sure if
it makes a leap of faith but I think it
moves maybe the the region be a faith is
active that's interesting yeah a lot of
people who work for you when I when I
see them giving interviews and what have
you they have the luster they have to
glow in there I yes it is the same kind
by halacha mental you have it too if it
looks like exactly the same kind of look
that people have who are very serious
about their religion yes but if you are
serious about what you are doing you
should like it you should love it and
that should be seen in your eyes yeah if
I don't see it in your eyes then you
don't tell me the right thing okay let's
let's have a look you've we've got today
with us we've got this wonderful
wonderful book about the Large Hadron
Collider where the particle collider
that is the old big machine another at
the heart of your research and what we
find in this book there's some wonderful
wonderful photos and many of them are of
the people who work for you the kind of
people we've just been talking about
let's just have a look at one or two of
those photos
and you could perhaps to tell me about
that photo let's a theorist a very
well-known cos that John Ellis was
instrumental or was instrumental in our
in our theory division he's now retired
but still active but yeah he's
developing theories okay and when you
talk about he's developing theories when
you see that stuff on the blackboard at
the back yeah right understanding you
don't understand it oh I hope you know
yeah that's a great relief to me because
I I was assuming that you look at that
and you read it like I read the football
results or something like that look
there are specialists and uh okay mus
have a look at another one oh that is a
wonderful shot this is a fantastic shot
and I can guarantee to you that the
person sitting there would know exactly
where to find which document unless you
start cleaning the office yeah that's
his office at this officer turn or the
boss's office attorneys I think now
retired and the reason why you're
telling me that he knows exactly where
to find what he's looking for it because
you are that kind of person I'm guessing
yes I'm normally always another person
with no one to keep order um so I'm very
happy that I have very good assistants
who taker who bring my things into order
mm-hmm the problem is I don't know where
they are I completely depend on them but
that's that's called delegation and
that's called confirmation absolutely
let's have a look at one more from the
book ah yeah that's a young lady we've
ever working together many years ago in
another experiment and she's a climber
I'm so she trained there and to Angie
and she's a scientist who works at CERN
as well yeah okay that that's good
because that leads me on to the question
most people again another cliche assumed
that science geeks are men no we also
have ladies how many around twenty
percent roughly which is the sandwich is
quite good for such technical science we
have quite a few young ladies I am very
pleased about it who operate the machine
this big accelerator a great scientist
figure that is that number on the rise
it's slowly rising but at least I slowly
it takes time yeah yeah what you see if
you don't you first have to have the
people who do this
these that I have to go into University
then they have to stay at the University
they have to continue so and then only
after that we plug in so it depends what
comes from the bottom but we are trying
to help everybody to make working and
life easier at Sur ok now we'll just be
looking at some of the photos from this
from this wonderful book if you'd like
to have a go at winning a copy of the
book called quite simply LHC then all
you have to do is to visit our website
at www de forward slash talking Germany
you'll find all the information you need
there and there is just one thing you
ought to bear in mind please do get your
email to us within 14 days now on a
different matter the academic world here
in Germany has been thrown into turmoil
by the recent resignation of the
country's long-serving Minister for
education and research her name aneta
Siobhan and she was a close political
ally of Chancellor Angela Merkel she was
forced to quit over allegations of
plagiarism in the dissertation that she
wrote three decades ago before we talked
about this story let's have a quick look
now at how and why plagiarism is being
exposed ID professor Deborah vaibhav
wolf doesn't think much of witch hunts
nevertheless she's been working in the
internet community for years exposing
plagiarism in doctoral theses to fact
lecture halls she reports on her methods
and tries to awaken people's awareness
of how important honest scholarship is
in the academic world there have been a
spate of recent high-profile plagiarism
controversies involving German
politicians brought to light on a
variety of Internet platforms according
to an Internet survey the typical
plagiarism spotter is a male graduate
about 38 years of age who is driven by a
sense of injustice Florida Sarah people
have written their own doctoral theses
and really worked on them see people
who've acquired their titles by cutting
and pasting as a pastiche together and
parading them proudly doctor to to clean
their furious they're angry isn't
shouldn't dissing so when CDU politician
aneta Siobhan's doctor'll title was
revoked in February 2013 it led to her
resignation for eight years she had been
Germany's minister for education and
research in 1980 she wrote her thesis in
philosophy at heinrich heine university
into zoloft an internal University
Commission checked her work after
accusations of plagiarism and declared
it invalid Rashard munch is a professor
in bham back in the early 1980s he was
also at the University in Dusseldorf and
New Siobhan's doctoral advisor some say
her work should have been checked more
closely but that wasn't as easy back
then or the con man eine suck mashina
nowadays you can use a search engine and
find the appropriate passages back then
you'd have to go through all the
original sources yourself to see to what
extent text passages had been
plagiarized visage a well-known the
unmanned hitta you'd have had to employ
someone for several weeks to do it
though in May all welcome to meet by
shifting listen deep
vive voix doesn't see yourself as a
hunter stalking her prey but as a
researcher like most of her fellow
campaigners she thinks exposing
plagiarism is important I'd say must be
Hall we have the currency we have in
scholarship is our honesty we have to
say this or that person wrote such and
such and this is my contribution in
scholarship we talk about standing on
the shoulders of giants and we should
name those giants on resumes an open end
where aneta siobhan is concerned at
least the internet and academic
communities are divided Devo Aviva wolf
says that other people who were involved
in more extreme cases have retained
their doctorates but that doesn't affect
her mission Roth tita hoya PhD
heidelberg university 1977 yeah
professor Hamburg University you must
have you must have thought long and hard
about that story yeah what can you share
those thoughts with us well at least I
have followed the story because it was
everywhere in the in the in the social
media and in the newspapers but I'm not
living in Germany but I'm of course
following it I'm first of all we have
everywhere in science we have to work to
the highest ethical standards that's
absolutely clear yeah science has to
keep its credibility that's one thing
but also people who are looking into
likewise obliteration or or in the word
they should also follow these standards
of course and it was a lot disgusting in
the social media here's out enough input
I mean you talk about things that you
only know a little bit about it you need
to know more about what is behind it but
what was the value of this work yeah
nobody has ever discuss I at least what
what I saw nobody has discussed what was
the value of the thesis there is of
course you have to be credible you have
to be up to the highest standards it
means you have to quote you have to make
the citations that's
absolutely i fully are i fully supported
but I mean 30 years ago it was also more
difficult to do what they think so but I
think the debate was also wrong because
the report about the PhD thesis was
published of us was open open to the
public before even the person involved
has seen it is this the right way to do
it important question important question
or certain standard are there too and
what we do usually when we have problems
be technical or non-technical we ask
external experts to assess it to do it
only internally I would do it
differently okay the people is too much
prominence given in Germany to the
doctor title it's a bit of a fetish in
Germany I mean you know in politics we
staff doctor call helmet call would be
introduced as a doctor and people
outside Germany would think what is he a
medical doctor and people put it on
their on their door bells & at meetings
people are introduced as dr. so and so
on dr. so-and-so yeah well for some
people maybe yes in some countries in my
player also even a stronger all in a
more prominent role i can tell you my
business card contains neither the
doctor nor the professor ok that's just
the name yeah i did my PhD because I
wanted to stay in research yeah and then
you do your your your PhD and actually
the PhD brings you forward because it's
a project that you impressive it's a
politic that you learn to do something
on your own of course still with the
Skylands but you learn to do a project
and so it's a normal way to to ponca sin
in academia but if if i am called doctor
or not I usually don't care there's an
irony so oldest at a net search around
the minister who had to go we've just
been hearing about her story she was she
was particularly involved and much
admired for her efforts to boost the
status of German universities in recent
years how good you know you want yeah
you want to come back around there
there's a point you want to make tell me
yeah I think I think she did a very good
too
turn if you look how much we did in
order to secure the funding for
education and research I must say she
did a very good job there I mean this is
something which one has to admire of
course it's different from from
receiving a PhD so there are two
different stories but what she did you
in that time I think was this scene from
the outside compared with other
countries very very useful and very good
for german research but concerning
german universities I mean to have an
excellent university is fine but can a
university be excellent in all aspect in
on all fields I think it's more
important to our situation in which
fields do we have excellent universities
now so university a is excellent in for
example in physics but not as excellent
maybe in agriculture another one is
excellent in agriculture or other
soldiers so what is Germany good at give
me a very quick answer we have very good
German universities concerning physics
and particle physics I must say there
you go very good damn ok but that's my
own and I know it best ok
a multi-faceted genius good I I
sometimes wonder whether for people
outside Germany Goethe isn't a little
bit like the Higgs particle that they've
many people have heard about it but they
don't really know what it is yeah could
well be could well be good for you what
maybe even for some Germans ok what is
what is go to mean to you he means a lot
he was a fantastic writer yeah uh I
quote sometimes pieces of a far worse
than me because that's a very I had to
work a lot on the force and in school at
that time and beginning I was not too
sure but then I started to like it yeah
and at the same time he was also a
scientist he was interested in science
yep and I think he isn't one of the good
examples I mean Leonardo da Vinci is
another perfect example of this type of
science and arts together yep it's
interesting cuz you talking about quotes
you talk about goethe i have written one
down here from Goethe man owes as long
as he strives it's a nice quote yeah and
it sounds an awful lot like the kind of
scientific methodology that I've heard
you proteins speaking about progress is
not a linear development no it's more or
less the same thing yeah yes because
linear as a sort of based based always
on the other thing so it's just a
continuous development if you want to
make a leap forward you have to bring in
unconventional ideas baby blue maybe
blue sky research and that means elite
yeah and this is what i would call
innovation yeah this goes up yep this is
nonlinear it brings to mind that there's
a very famous quote by the irish writer
samuel beckett yeah try again fail again
fail better yes yeah it's nice because
you'll fail quite often but you learn
from your failure yeah yeah and you
learn more from failures than from your
successes a few you know a lot of you
work together with an awful lot of very
very bright people for intelligent
people have you have you ever met a
universal genius Universal this far it's
a big term isn't it is very got scared
people who are extremely
right extremely sharp yeah I'd universal
is too much too much okay we've talked
about Germans reading Goethe or not
reading Goethe as the case may be I
think most Germans if you ask them would
be able to name a politician or to a
racing driver sports star a banker
possibly a journalist yeah they probably
wouldn't be able to name a scientist is
there something wrong there is there a
problem there's something wrong yeah and
it's a problem yeah tell me because at
the beginning of the 20th century people
were talking about science about
scientists about relativity theory
quantum mechanics whatever i'm not sure
if they understood a lot but they were
talking about it it was exciting it was
excited were heroes yes and that's
missing today hmm yeah because if you
take away everything what is coming out
of relativity theory or from quantum
mechanics you take away all the silicon
developments you take away your GPS
because Einstein is in the GPS system if
you don't use Einstein you don't end up
in your studio you end up in the spray
and for the outside people the river is
a river yeah okay and you would like to
avoid this so you need this basic
science and you need to talk about
science because science is the basis of
what we had on which our life is as
young as based on you need to generate
more enthusiasm with with school kids I
mean you talked about your teacher you
talked about being at school and picking
up on science you know my kids and then
the circles that they move in i don't
there aren't many of them that are
saying i can see myself working in
science well maybe it's also sometimes
because the parents are not happen you
mean i started i'm reading goethe you do
you have to do both things yeah you have
to be supportive but not demanding and
that's I think the right balance I think
the general attitude is that science is
too difficult yeah science is not
difficult yeah yeah because you can
understand that at least some basic
facts of science without mathematics
it's the logic which counts and once you
overcome this threshold that it's it's
difficult then you start love no not
maybe not loving it but accepting it and
sometimes talking about it look I had I
had a taxi driver in Helsinki who drove
me to the airport asking where I'm going
and I said I fly to Geneva and he said
what I'm doing the oil i'm working at
journey said ok I know about your work
oh because I saw the film angels and
demons yeah and through that film I got
so much interested in your science that
I've watched your web page every day
this is what we need that's that is
enthusiasm ok we've just got time for a
couple of quiz questions at the end of
the show the traditional quiz some tough
ones philosophical questions I'm afraid
wisdom or knowledge wisdom inspiration
or persistence persistence mechanisms or
miracles
I think I take the Mickens I knew you
were going to we're gonna have to leave
it there ever this is a lot need to hire
a charming diplomatic man of science if
you want to find out more do read my
blog on the talking Germany internet
site you can also of course watch any
shows that you might have missed online
and if you've enjoyed today's show as
much as I have then do come back next
week until then bye bye and tryst
you
you